absolument media so have a situation in
my apartment right now I have a surplus
of pickle juice in my apartment
there's too much pickle juice cuz after
the pics are gone I don't like to throw
out the pickle juice it just feels
wasteful so lately I've been dipping my
fingers in the pickle juice and then I'm
picking on my sandwiches for flavor
[Applause]
how many flicks would you take to
properly flavor ham sandwich uh between
7 and 11 depending on how big your
fingers are and how long you let them
rest in the pickle juice there's lots of
variables I've studied this I get home
one day all the pickle juice is gone my
roommate I know I said I live alone
earlier but like I said I like to
establish different realities for every
joke it's more fun that way so I asked
my roommate hey what happened to all the
pickle juice he said I threw it I threw
it out it's just pickle juice it's not
just pickle juice don't ever you don't
just try to trivialize and simplify
pickle juice it's not just that I flick
it on my sandwiches for flavor and say
hey yo you know I got to hurt one of
your lizards now
he got like seven lizards that's way too
many lizards they don't do [ __ ] they're
not even famous lizards they never been
on Animal Planet or anything it does
lizard regular as lizards just chill in
the apartment then they have lights on
them all day
they don't do [ __ ] down putting nothing
on the bills just sitting in light I
paid for the light bill
I'm fry one of those lizards have a
lizard sandwich and then flick pickle
juice on my bucket welcome to that solar
Fest security rope the venue is 300 but
the security room is 300 times 2 we got
600 employees dedicated to security
making sure your experience is one of
the purest